si ya llegaste hasta aquí entonces ya
llevas esperando un buen rato para
encontrar la línea que minimiza los
cuadrados de distancias verticales a los
puntos para ya no hacerlo tanto de
emoción terminamos este último paso
resolviendo nuestro sistema para m y
para b siguiendo con la idea del vídeo
pasado hay dos formas de concluir una
forma es que ya conocemos dos puntos en
la línea de modo que podemos encontrar
la pendiente m y b la ordenada al origen
o bien podemos resolver el sistema de
ecuaciones lo cual es matemáticamente
equivalente
vamos a intentar encontrar el valor de m
en este sistema de ecuaciones queremos
cancelar las veces entonces voy a
reescribir la ecuación de arriba como
como m por el promedio de las x es
cuadradas + b por el promedio de las no
sabes que creo que podemos hacer esto
mucho mejor y mucho más fácil porque ya
trabajamos un poquito en vez de hacer
eso voy a simplemente restar estas dos
ecuaciones que están aquí la azulita y
la verdecita vale entonces déjame restar
las voy a sumar la versión negativa de
esta igualdad
entonces que obtenemos a ver nos queda
una m factor izada por el promedio de
las x es menos el promedio de las x es
cuadradas dividido entre el promedio de
las x es y a la vez se cancela con la b
no nos queda nada y eso es igual a el
promedio de las es menos el promedio de
las x es dividido entre el promedio de
las x es ahora si queremos despejar m
simplemente hay que dividir ambos lados
entre este término que nos queda nos
queda que m es igual a el promedio de
las es menos el promedio de las x
dividido entre el promedio de las x
dividido entre el promedio de las x es
menos el promedio de las x es cuadradas
ahora observa que esto es exactamente lo
mismo que obtener la pendiente de la
recta porque tenemos que hacer el cambio
en a ver la diferencia de las
coordenadas es justo esto y luego hay
que dividir entre el cambio de las x es
que es justo
a coordenada - esta coordenada y eso es
el denominador de acá ahora para
simplificar un poco podemos multiplicar
y dividir por el promedio de las equis
es voy a hacer eso para evitar las
fracciones en fracciones entonces a ver
qué nos queda nos queda el promedio de
las x es multiplicado por el promedio de
las es baja menos este se cancela con
este menos el promedio del producto de
las x es / dividido entre aquí abajo nos
queda el promedio por el promedio que es
el promedio de las x es elevado al
cuadrado y luego y luego la x se cancela
con la equis entonces nos queda menos el
promedio de las x es cuadradas las x es
cuadradas promediadas muy bien esto de
aquí es lo que obtenemos para m este es
el valor de m ya es una constante verdad
ahora si queremos resolver para ver si
queremos despejar b podemos sustituir en
alguna de estas la azulita nos conviene
la azulita se ve mucho más sencilla que
la otra entonces si queremos encontrar
el valor de b
en términos de m lo que queremos hacer
es restar mx de ambos lados de esta
ecuación y obtendríamos que no no a ver
obtendríamos que b es igual al promedio
de las yes - m veces el promedio de las
x es entonces lo que tendría que hacer
es tomar tu información
encontrar los promedios de las x es de
las yes de los productos y de las x es
cuadradas sacar todos esos promedios
determinar m y con eso en esta otra
fórmula puedes determinar el valor de b
con eso ya tendrías la mlb que nos da en
la línea óptima uff
con esto terminamos estoy aquí son las
dos fórmulas recién sacadas del horno
para encontrar la mejor línea según el
error cuadrática en el siguiente vídeo
ahí si alguien se estaba saltando toda
la prueba ahorita es cuando debería de
reincorporarse pero en el siguiente
vídeo vamos a usar estas fórmulas que
acabamos de encontrar para determinar la
mejor línea con el criterio del error
cuadrática en algunos ejemplos vale nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo para fijar
todas estas ideas